le cinquième il a révolutionné la
musique dans les années 80 et pourtant
ce clavier est bien plus vieux que ce
que vous croyez en 1928 maurice martenot
créé les ondes martenot
c'est exact et après plus de trente ans
de perfectionnement les ondes martenot
ça donne ça tombe bien
ou bien
pendant que monsieur martenot travailler
sur son appareil dans les années 40 une
autre invention synthétiser des sondés
autres instruments il s'agit de l'undd
violine des castagnettes au cor de
chasse de chasse le banjo d'accord au
piano et allons violine de ce jour là
c'est jean-jacques perrey le pionnier de
la musique électro il a collaboré avec
stanley kubrick et walt disney rien que
ça il nous reste qu'à dire bravo à la
musique française électronique
oui mais pas trop vite non plus certes
cette musique est prisé dans le cinéma
mais quand le public français la
découvre un concert au début des années
70 voilà ce qu'il en pense
c'était vraiment je ne mets pas du moche
en quelques années ce sera pour cela il
n'a pas fallu attendre bien longtemps
l'informatique est passée par là le
synthé ouvre de nouvelles perspectives
un certain jean michel jarre s'en empare
et devient un grand nom de la musique
électronique c'est la première fois
qu'un compositeur à la possibilité de
travailler sur le sont exactement comme
un sculpteur travaille sur sa pierre
avant on pouvait juste combiné des notes
des accords entre eux maintenant on veut
travailler sur le sont presque
manuellement six années 80 90
ça y est la musique électro est devenu
populaire à tel point que la france lui
dédie une journée par an à paris la
techno parade depuis 1990
et bien évidemment vous aurez reconnu
les notes de synthétiseurs
[Musique]